- [Interpreter] Hi, I'm Nyle DiMarco
and I'm here to read your thirsty tweets.
(mellow music)
You can just tell Nyle
DiMarco has a nice (bleep).
It's in his eyes.
Maybe.
When I die, please scatter my ashes
on Nyle DiMarco's chest hair.
I'm not sure if I want that.
I'd probably have to shower
like two or three times that night.
Nyle DiMarco could use me as a hand puppet
to be honest.
I don't know what that means.
Do you know what that means?
Like a hand puppet?
Oh (laughs).
How do you sign, I want to suck your toes?
All right, so, here are your toes,
I wanna suck them.
Hey, Nyle DiMarco, if you need someone
to apply oil on your abs for
photo shoots, let me know.
Absolutely, I'll be putting
out applications pretty soon,
so, keep an eye out.
I hated facial hair
until I saw Nyle DiMarco.
Mm, that's an honor, thank you.
Nyle DiMarco could punch me in the throat
and I'd be like, oh, damn, you right.
I don't need to breathe.
Yeah, but I don't wanna punch you!
I need all of you alive on this earth.
Mood, Nyle DiMarco's hairy thighs.
You know, it's getting
pretty close to summer,
I might just shave it all off.
When I say I want Nyle DiMarco
to suffocate me to death
with his naked body,
I actually mean I want Nyle
DiMarco to suffocate me
with his naked body.
Come give me a hug.
Unless they're on Nyle DiMarco,
I could really care less about abs.
I think a lot of people
have better abs than me,
but thank you.
Nyle DiMarco could literally
shove his foot up my ass
and I'd say thank you.
I'm not sure what to say to that,
but you're welcome?
Not sure if I want to do that either.
Nyle DiMarco could literally chokeslam me
into a pit of acid.
Like I said, I need all of my fans alive.
I don't want any of you to die.
Thank you so much for all your tweets.
I'm looking forward to
seeing more in the future.
You're all talking crazy.
(slow, sensual music)